[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain alors est-ce que
emmanuel macron va pousser coûte que
coûte la dernière grande réforme de son
quinquennat la réforme des retraites qui
pourrait mettre le feu aux poudres dans
le contexte sanitaire qu'on connaît tous
bien on al impression qu effectivement
c'est le dernier coup de force 1 le
sprint avant la ligne d'arrivée de 2022
il faut faire passer cette réforme sans
quoi son bilan de réformateurs sera à
peu près 0 et vis-à-vis des électeurs de
droite qu'ils essayent de dragué depuis
des mois ça ferait quand même un léger
trouble un léger malaise donc il y a eu
un déjà une campagne autour de cette
réforme des retraites qui est
indispensable dont on n'aurait pas le
choix de faire l'économie qui doit
arriver et qui va forcément arriver la
question c'est quand et bruno le maire
en parlait les différents porte parole
de la république en marche en parle
également et le président qui laisse
planer le doute en disant que oui il
devra prendre des décisions difficiles
peut-être durant l'été qui pourrait
peut-être compromettre sa candidature
donc ça pourrait être cette réforme des
retraites qui rappelez-vous avait mis à
tous les partenaires sociaux dans la rue
demandant davantage de débats davantage
de clarifications
il y avait eu de nombreux couacs 1 le
monsieur retraites jean paul delvaux
avait été obligé de démissionner suite à
ses nombreux mandats qu'ils n'avaient
pas déclaré et tout ça avait continué
ensuite avec le candidat malheureux de
la république en marche dans les hauts
de france également qui avait pris le
dossier retraite donc ce dossier
retraites à l'arrêt on a l'impression
que neil mac on veut absolument le
remettre sur la table et le pousser
jusqu'au bout
en bien décalant l'âge de la retraite
jusqu'à 64 ans de même si ce n'était pas
dans son programme
au contraire sa promesse de programmes
c'était de ne pas décaler l'âge du
départ à la retraite dans les cinq ans
qui viennent
or il parle maintenant de réforme
paramétrique et on sent bien qu'il est
gêné parce que cette réforme elle est
demandée par bruxelles dans les
conditions du plan de relance de
l'argent européen ces 40 milliards
donnés par bruxelles enfin prêter
puisqu'il s'agit de dettes et d'emprunts
et bien il faut que la france accepte de
faire des réformes systémiques retraites
mais aussi bien sur l'assurance-chômage
assurance chômage qui elle aussi
un coup d'arrêt suite à l'avis du
conseil d'état qui a expliqué que ce
n'était pas forcément le moment compte
tenu aujourd'hui de l'état du marché de
l'emploi
pas forcément en très bonne santé même
si les prédictions de bruno le maire
reste tout à fait optimiste à 5% contre
parfois la vie de la banque de france
qui s'inquiète de l'apparition du delta
du variant delta bien sûr et de
l'incertitude qui plane encore sur la
reprise économique mais voilà où on en
est aujourd'hui
visiblement coûte que coûte emmanuel
macron veut réformer les retraites avant
son départ rien président alexis tout
occupé à la relance un kit en oublier
les autres priorités
oui c'est assez incroyable de voir
l'agenda du président de la république
il était la semaine dernière à
l'ouverture de la samaritaine ouvert par
bernard arnault en fondant longtemps les
nombreux emplois qui étaient là et le
luxe à la française qui allait
accueillir de nombreux touristes
quand la crise sanitaire sera derrière
nous il était hier à douai pour
l'inauguration d'une usine
sino-japonaises de batteries électriques
avec xavier bertrand le président
vainqueur des régionales de la région de
france avec une passe d'armes entre les
deux hommes tout à fait lunaire ou
xavier bertrand lui parle de
l'abstention de la difficulté de
raccrocher les wagons avec le peuple
français emmanuel macron qu'il lui parle
de la relance et de l'importance
finalement de travail est de faire de
l'emploi
et puis ensuite il se met en scène comme
d'habitude avec un micro au milieu des
des ouvriers pour expliquer que c'est
formidable investissement dans d'autres
pays et le soir même il était à
versailles pour dîner avec des grands
patrons du monde entier c'était le
sommet choose france des patron
d'arcelormittal mais aussi de la banque
d'affaires jpmorgan et bien d'autres qui
étaient autour du président cette fois
ci pour promettre 7000 emplois selon
bruno le maire c'est bien peu quand on
sait les milliards que brasse ces
multinationales qui sont à peu près
partout dans le même temps arcelormittal
si elle choisit la france
eh bien elle quitte l'italie où elle est
en train l'a22 de liquides et de
nombreuses usines et donc on voit bien
qu'il ya comme ça une volonté d'être
celui qui va lancer la relance d'une
certaine façon comme il peut le faire
comme il essaye de le faire
systématiquement parce que maintenant
son bilan sera aussi celui là est ce que
les 5 % promis par bercy sont possibles
c'est pas forcément ce que pense la
banque de france aujourd'hui et puis est
ce que laisse la place d'un président
français d'être à l'ouverture des locaux
d'une banque d'affaires américaine jp
morgan à paris je trouve ça légèrement
déplacé de voir le président se déplacer
lui-même personnellement pour féliciter
c'est financiers internationaux qui
viennent simplement la sphère des
affaires parce que le break site est
passée par là il ya là un message tout à
fait biaisé et on voit bien la
difficulté qu'a emmanuel macron à
incarner la fonction de chef d'état il
est là dans son rôle plutôt de vendeur
international comme il l'avait fait en
héros de la start up nation et il fait
ça pour quoi pour attirer des
investisseurs étrangers et dire que
finalement la france redémarre et pour
ce faire et bien il réforme le marché de
l'emploi il réforme des retraites et il
continue finalement le brader les bijoux
de famille un c'était le cas avec alstom
et puis aussi la république sociale qui
visiblement en huile et les
investisseurs aient beaucoup
d'incertitudes électrique ou d'un le
delta vous avez par et la croissance et
une stratégie politique
ton même difficile à lire il faut jouer
les équilibristes complètement on
on voit que la stratégie aujourd'hui des
mâles macron c'est celle de l'autruche
il fait comme si les élections
régionales n'avait pas eu lieu
il fait comme si le variant delta
n'existait pas ou n'existera pas cet été
on verra plus tard à la rentrée comment
ça se passera et il est uniquement
concentré sur son art hâtif sur le tempo
qu'il veut se donner personnellement
pour relancer sa campagne
c'est le discours du 14 juillet
extrêmement attendu avec beaucoup de
communication autour de ce discours
comme celui de la refondation
on attend de voir ce qu'il va vraiment
dire il est aussi question de réunir le
parlement en congrès à versailles pour
faire des annonces alors serait ce les
fameuses annonces sur les retraites et
d'autres choses on attend et on a
l'impression comme ça que il essaye d
entretenir un suspense permanent parce
qu'il n'a rien à dire parce qu'il veut
le dire au bon moment quand les français
seront en vacances quand ils vont
oublier quand ils ne pourront pas
descendre dans la rue ou ne voudront pas
ou quand il va falloir peut-être prendre
des mesures de restrictions sanitaires à
cause bien sûr de la multiplication du
variant delta sur le territoire donc
c'est illisible
évidemment c'est beaucoup d'incertitudes
y compris pour les milieux économiques
qui se demande finalement si emmanuel
macron incapable de tenir quelques unes
de ses promesses puisque les réformes
n'arrive pas elles sont trop lentes à
venir et si jamais il fallait
voulait les faire trop rapidement ça
pourrait braqué bien sûr l'opinion
publique et amener davantage de blocage
comme on l'avait vu lors du 49 3 et de
la première mouture de cette réforme des
retraites donc clairement aujourd'hui sa
stratégie c'est celle de gagner du temps
de continuer à se mettre en scène avec
ses pérégrinations au sein du pays
auprès des usines des ouvriers puis des
populations et d'essayer de de
reconnecter avec la population française
il est aidé en cela par des instituts de
sondages complaisants qui continuent à
donner des sondages où il est toujours
en train de monter alors que réellement
je crois que il ya quand même beaucoup
d'incertitudes autour de la cote de
popularité des mails macro et de ses
capacités et à réformer et à donner une
ligne claire pour la suite des
opérations
alors justement dans ce contexte comment
peut-il s'assurer une chance de
réélection en 2022 si les candidats mais
la première des choses que doit faire
emmanuel macron s'il veut se donner une
chance et si il se représente c'est de
clarifier les choses
aujourd'hui tout est flou et quand c'est
flou et bien ça comme on dit c'est qu'il
ya un loup et on le sait bien s'il veut
passer la réforme des retraites il doit
être clair il doit pour cela engager une
nouvelle grande concertation en disant
que cela n'arrivera qu'après l'élection
de 2022
il ne peut pas vouloir la faire passer
de force avant donc peut-être que là il
sera mal un dedans en jouant le temps
avec les partenaires sociaux
et puis l'autre choses extrêmement
importantes s'il veut aussi pouvoir se
présenter face aux français il doit
clarifier leurs même temps le en même
temps a atteint sa limite extrême quand
on a vu la passe d'armes entre le
ministre de l'intérieur et le ministre
de la justice qui ne viennent pas du
même bord politique
on comprend bien que ce gouvernement de
jean castex ne tient qu'à un fil
il y a trop de sensibilités politiques
différentes les régionales sont passées
par là beaucoup de ministres et bien ont
perdu et les ego aussi ont pris beaucoup
dans cette bataille et ce qu'ils
pouvaient tenir avec beaucoup de
communication beaucoup d'enrobage ne
tient plus parce que l'idéologie prime
est aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
clairement essaye de draguer les
électeurs de droite de devenir un
candidat de droite
sa stratégie après avoir diminué le
parti socialiste était celle de diminuer
les républicains or les résultats des
régionales revigore ces deux anciens
partis parce qu'ils ont sauvé les
régions qu'ils avaient est presque aussi
il montre que existe au local
aux régionales eaux territoriales aux
municipales et que ce seront des parties
ancré dans les territoires qui
connaissent le pays là où la république
en marche ce n'est qu'un parti parisiens
finalement loin des réalités et emmanuel
macron aux dires de certains de ses
conseillers qui se bunkérise encore
davantage à l'elysée et qui ne voit plus
du tout finalement quels sont les
ficelles pour tirer et l reconnecter
avec le pays réel donc la qualification
sera difficile pour lui parce que ça
veut dire qu'il abandonnera une grande
partie de son jeu politique qui était
d'être est de ne pas être d'être le en
même temps permanent et de dire tout et
son contraire
maintenant il va devoir dire des choses
et surtout les assumer merci alex signé
pour l'un d'avoir été avec nous pour à
votre édito